Thank You Jimmy um i'ma c function has
got two associations company i was last
dancer make a comment on your question
on one of them in each stage our next
year under give reportable i smile will
be perfectly honest I don't have an
answer to your specific question what I
would like to encourage some water
changes actually that if you think
beyond mitigation which is an extremely
important element and and the thicker
about climate adaptation we can actually
bring that and forward on stage jointly
with governments Johnny with setting the
right incentives actually these were
supported mex elimination that is my
bond love than the answer to your
question but that was asked not to be so
that's what I did thank you sir may I
have you